great okay perfect
so a sample from this model uh looks
like this so they also point to 99.6
billion dollars from 200 400 63
no um it's a bunch of kind of gibberish
um so the sentence isn't too coherent uh
but at least the words do seem to be
somewhat related like they come from the
same space
now jumping forwards to the beginning of
the deep learning room in 2011 we have
language modeling with neural networks
now and in particular with recurrent
neural networks
so we can get rid of this giant lookup
table from the engram models and instead
we can uh have our inputs be these
tokens and let this kind of recurrent
cell remember some state and persistent
state
so if we set up a neural model like this
we get a sample
as shown below so the meaning of life is
the tradition of the ancient human
reproduction is less favorable to the
good boy for one to remove bigger so
again
this doesn't really make any sense but
it kind of starts to have the flow of a
real sentence
yeah so jumping forward even more to
2016 we have lstm models and
um of course lstms are an architectural
innovation on top of rnns and they have
kind of better gradient flow so they're
better to they can better model
long-term dependencies
and so with an lstm model we get a
sample like this with even more new
technologies coming onto the market
quickly during the past three years an
increasing number of companies
must tackle the ever-changing and
ever-changing environmental challenges
online so this sentence is starting to
make a little bit of sense though there
are clear artifacts like the repetition
of the phrase ever changing
now starting in uh 2018 we have our
first auto aggressive transformer based
language models which are even better at
modeling these very long term uh
dependencies
and here what i'm showing is an example
of a completion so
in a completion you the user uh supplies
the prompt uh in this case it's this uh
text swings over kansas
and um the model will will continue from
this prompt
so you can see that uh this completion
is coherent across multiple sentences
now though there are notable spelling
mistakes so you see this like uh what
whatever document is so
uh it doesn't quite make sense
and now we arrive at gpg2 which is a 1.5
billion parameter transformer model
and i copied in what i personally found
was the most compelling completion from
gpd2
and
uh in contrast with the last slide what
this does is it sets up a clearly fake
prompt so this
uh we have something about finding
unicorns and scientists um in south
america
and so the model has probably not seen
this exact prompt before and has to make
up something that's consistent
so
the thing i find most impressive is
it does so and it's coherent across
multiple paragraphs it invents this
fictional dr perez and
it persists perez throughout multiple
paragraphs and
i think it's like very aptly named you
have him from university of la paz and
um yeah we just have fairly coherent
completions at this point
so it's worth disclosing that this was
the best of 10 samples so uh we still
have to sample uh multiple times to get
a sample like this
and finally uh to end this semester yeah
for sure
the
yeah so this is human judge yeah i'll
probably expand a little bit on that
more today yeah
so i want to end this kind of fly by
overview with gpd3
and since g52 already produces such
coherent text like uh
how do you characterize gp23 and i would
say that the best way to do so is that
say you took the best of like one
best out of five or ten completions from
ppd2 that would be kind of your first
conclusion from gpt3 and uh of course
best is kind of a personal uh metric
here
um so here i'm showing uh completion
from the the
three body problem um
and
you can see that the impressive things
about this completion are that it really
stays true to the style of of the novel
um i think the second thing that kind of
impressed me was just how poetic like
the metaphors and similes that it
produces are so you have this
stuff like blood was sleeping through
her jacket and a dark red flower is
blooming on her chest like uh he's kind
of like very very poetic and stylistic
sentences
so he definitely understands it's part
of a novel and it's trying to generate
this kind of prose that
in the same style
so as generated text becomes more and
more coherent i think one really outputs
how much bigger interest parameters
yeah yeah so it's 175 billion parameters
versus uh gpt2 which is one around one
vote
[Music]
do you feel like that
very subtle increase in accuracy
right
yeah yeah that's a very good question so
um there's kind of stuff maybe we can
dive into it a little bit after but
there is work on kind of neural scaling
laws and so the idea is like can you
predict the performance of a larger
model from a series of smaller models
and so i would rather characterize the
increase in performance not by kind of
the small gain in perplexity but like
whether it lines up with the projections
and in that sense gpt3 does um so
yeah that's some intuition for for yeah
i think
personally at open air we would have
stopped the experiment if it didn't so
yeah no i just think it's interesting
machine learning you see people pushing
for like an extra you know one percent
or like 25 percent accuracy but the
models are increasing in a scale that's
functional right so i wonder sometimes
whether it's worth it and like where you
should stop
right yeah i think maybe this side will
get to it a little bit but there's also
some sense in which like uh as you reach
kind of like the entropy floor of
modeling um like every having kind of
gives you uh like like
if you think about accuracy right that
it's not on a linear scale right like a
one percent early on isn't the same as
that last one
and so um yeah the those last bits
really do
help you squeeze a little bit out of
that okay
yep sorry
oh yes yes sorry this is accuracy and i
i will explain this yeah cool
so yeah um so as as generated text
becomes more and more realistic i think
one very natural question to ask is
whether humans can still distinguish
between real and fake attacks right and
so in here we have a
this is of course like a a very set up
scenario it's not in all cases the model
is able to trick humans but this is for
uh for news articles we kind of
presented gpt3 generated samples against
real news articles and you can tell kind
of as the number of parameters increases
the ability of humans to distinguish
between the real and fake articles
that ability goes down to near random
chance
oh yes
how did you generate the news articles
oh um i
i'm actually not completely sure um so
i didn't do this work particularly but i
i think one possible approach would be
to prime with a couple of news articles
and then just to have a delimiter and
just have it start generating user
requests from there
yeah
any other questions
great
so even with all these impressive
results i think it's worth taking a step
back at this point and asking what do we
really care about language modeling for
and what is it actually useful for
i think one can make the argument that
it is actually a fairly narrow
capability like why would you just want
some system that just
continues text for you
uh and you can argue that there's more
important tasks to solve like
summarization or translation
and i think most researchers at hokume i
would agree with this point of view and
in fact gpt was not really a
project that was focused on language
modeling as an end goal but mostly as a
tool to solve
a problem called unsupervised learning
which i'm going to go through in the
next couple of slides so i want to
do a history of language modeling at
open ai and hopefully motivate why we
ended up at the gpt series of models and
kind of how we arrive
there and hopefully it'll become much
more intuitive after this section
so the deep learning group started in
2012 with alex
which was a system that could take
images and labels and they could
classify images to their labels and uh
what we found with alexnet was these
systems were able to generalize
surprisingly well like you could take
data sets that weren't necessarily the
training distribution and you still have
pretty good features
and um since then this kind of
supervised approach has been really
really powerful right we've been able to
train models in many different domains
to classify uh very accurately
and you can even have some guarantees
that supervised learning will work well
so there's empirical risk minimization
and but the problem with supervised
learning is that oftentimes the labels
are scarce right uh especially in
language tests there isn't really that
many kind of uh text paired with their
summaries or too many pairs across
languages for instance
so collecting a lot of data can be not
too hard but actually scalably labeling
all of that data it could be very time
consuming and expensive
so the main problem with unsupervised
learning is can we also learn from
unlabeled data and this is a lot scarier
because
all of a sudden we're starting to
optimize an objective which isn't the
one we care about downstream right so
there's a lot of the guarantees that we
used to have we no longer longer
and
we can only kind of hope that we learn
some features that are adaptable to a
wide variety of demonstrative tasks
but nevertheless there's a reason to be
very optimistic in language
and the reason is that there is a huge
pro of unlabeled data and it's called
the internet and so the real question is
can we leverage all this unlabeled data
from the internet
to solve language tasks where we don't
really have that much data
and the hope is that if we kind of
pre-train this model on the internet
they'll see all of these words used in
different settings kind of understand
their relationships
and they'll be able to leverage this
kind of understanding for for any kind
of task to learn
so now that we've established why
language is such a good domain to try
unsupervised learning in let's talk
about why use generative models for it
and also why use autoregressive
generative models
and i do want to stress that a lot of
the guarantees we have with supervised
learning are no longer there for
unsupervised learning so some of these
arguments will be a little bit kind of
intuitive and
um
so the first argument i want to present
is this quote by richard feynman which
is uh pretty widespread so what i cannot
create i do not understand
right and there's the inverse of this
idea which we call analysis by synthesis
and it's what i can create i can also
understand and this has been studied by
um kind of josh tenenbaum there's um
definitely some kind of biological
motivation as well for it
um
but
the the idea here is that if you're able
to
create a language model which can
generate diverse samples that are
coherent then it must also build up
representations that can help you solve
language understanding tasks
and then the next question is why do we
use autoregressive models you might
argue that autoregressive models are a
kind of local objective right like
you're just predicting the next words
you could do really well with kind of
some n-gram approximation right like
what why why would it be good at solving
things that allow you to summarize an
entire piece of facts
and so an intuitive argument here could
be say that you wanted to do very well
on uh language modeling for a mystery
novel
and uh there's this grand reveal at the
end like oh like the culprit was and
then you want to predict that next token
and to do really well at that task you
really need to have a good understanding
of what happened in the story along with
all the twists and turns and maybe even
some of this kind of like deductive
reasoning
so the first sign of life oh
did you have a question
oh
so the first sign of life we had at open
eye was in the task of predicting
whether amazon reviews uh were positive
or negative and this was work done in
2017 so instead of training a classifier
in the kind of typical supervised way
what we did was we trained an lstm model
just to predict the next character in
amazon reviews
when we trained a linear model on the
features from this lspm what we found
surprisingly was like one of these cells
or one of these neurons was firing in
terms of uh predicting sentiment and um
positive activations for this neuron
corresponding to positive reviews and
negative activations to negative reviews
and this was despite not being not
seeing any of the labels at training
time
so you can even track kind of what this
neuron value is across a
sample so it's a little bit hard to read
but these are reviews where maybe
someone says oh i really like this film
but i didn't like this part and you can
kind of see the sentiments switching and
as you go from positive to negative
so yeah just predicting the next
character
resulted in oh yeah
and one neuron is firing with yeah just
uh outsized predictive power yeah
great so next uh gpg one was one of the
first demonstrations that this kind of
approach could work broadly for techs so
g51 was trained on the internet uh not
on amazon reviews anymore
and it was fine too on a bunch of
different downstream tasks
right and
and one thing to stress here was uh kind
of to your point that the um the fine
tuning was very
i guess minimally kind of uh you're not
kind of bashing the architecture apart
and and um kind of repurposing a new
module so it's just a new new head that
classifies uh for your your tasks and
make sure that you can
use this approach not just for sentence
analysis
but also for like entailment synaptic
similarity and getting sodas on a lot of
these benchmarks downstream
so i've already presented gpg2 from the
point of view of a very powerful
language model and now i think it's
worth revisiting from the viewpoint of
unsupervised learning
so like gpt-1 gpg2 was trained on a
large chunk of the internet
and it's only trained to predict the
next token or word uh from previous
words but the key insight of gpd2 is
that many downstream tasks can be
expressed naturally as a language model
in the past
and yeah so gpt2 explores how well we
can perform on downstream tasks simply
by using this method without any
fine-tuning
right so let me start with a couple of
examples so let's say you want to solve
some reading comprehension benchmark and
this is usually set up as a prompt which
is some passage you have to read and
then a bunch of questions which you have
to answer so you can literally just
stick the entire prompting context you
put a question colon you write out the
question answer colon and then have the
model complete from there and this kind
of gives you zero shot reading
comprehension
we can also use it for other
tasks like summarization for instance
here's like a first the beginning of a
cnn article about kind of some some
archaeological finding and you can just
put tldr after you you see this passage
and the model hopefully if it's good
enough will produce good summaries
and the final example i want to show is
that you can do zero shot translation as
well
so
the way you would do this is if you
wanted to convert let's say a french
sentence into english you could set up a
prompt like the sentence insert defense
sentence translated from french to
english means
and then the model will complete um and
they can
sometimes do this well and one kind of
critical thing to note here is that uh
here's the chart of performance as you
increase the number of parameters
um and
um
in all these models they were trained on
the same data set so the only kind of
compounding variable is scale
and you can see that as we scale up the
models these kind of zero-shot
capabilities
emerge or and kind of
smoothly get better so the role of scale
is important here
and yeah and i think these are starting
to approach some i guess they're not
great benchmarks but at least
respectable
yep
yeah yeah yeah exactly it's not going to
be great in a lot of cases and to be
honest like uh the the blue metric used
for translation is actually often oh
thank you very much um
it's not a great metric what it does is
it takes a reference solution
and um basically
it does some kind of engram comparison
so
um
it is a big problem to have good
translation metrics uh in nlp and yeah i
i think um when i talk about code i will
talk a little bit more
right so let's finally talk about how
gpg3 fits into this picture
so the primary insight of gpd3 is that
the training process itself can be
interpreted in the context of metaler
which is kind of like learning over
distribution of tasks
and uh during training what the model's
doing is it's developing certain kind of
capabilities it's
um
picking up some set of like
skills in terms of modeling uh certain
passages
and um
during inference time when it's what
it's doing it's kind of quickly picking
up on what a task is based on what the
prompt is so far and
adapting to that task to predict the
next token so you can kind of view
there's this outward loop of all the sgd
steps you're doing during training and
this inward loop of kind of picking up
on what the task is and then modeling
the next token
so you can imagine a lot of
tasks being framed in this way for
instance on the left you can have
addition kind of you you have a lot of
examples of which machine context and
hopefully that would help you with a new
addition problem or you can try to
unscramble a word for instance and i'll
explore uh results on on these two kind
of benchmarks in the next slides
so
this setting we call fuchsia arithmetic
and just to explain what's going on
you're taking the entire context length
of your transformer and you're putting
in as many examples as will fit
and then finally you put in the the
example that you would like to solve
so uh here like uh these examples could
be um
these kind of first three addition
problems and then you you have 31 plus
41 equals and yes model to complete
so you notice that as the language model
gets bigger it's better able to
recognize this task and you can see that
kind of performance on on addition
subtraction even some kind of
multiplication tasks increases sharply
as you as you go towards 200 billion
parameters and there just seems to be
kind of some step function change right
here
and uh looking at word unscrambling uh
this is also true so um we have
parameters again on the x-axis we have
accuracy and each of these is a
different kind of unscrambled task so
this blue line is you kind of do a
cyclic shift of the letters and you want
it to uncycle um and there's a lot of
other transforms you can do like
randomly in certain words for instance
so the final point here is that this is
a pretty general phenomenon we didn't
just test it on on these two
aforementioned tasks
we tried an array of i think 40 plus
tasks and here you can see how the zero
shot one shot and fu shot performance
increases as we scale the models so of
course they're all smoothly increasing
but one thing to to be aware of is that
the gap between zero shot and fuchsia is
also improving as a function of scale
awesome
so we've just seen that we can pre-train
the transfer oh good
yeah
one is the tasks
themselves that were used two is the
number of parameters and then three my
understanding is also the quantity that
was suggested yeah i was curious sort of
between those three which ones it's
you've shown a lot of them because the
number of parameters definitely helps i
was curious knowing what i said so the
degree to which also the training tasks
and the sophistication of the tasks as
well as the quantity of the adjusted
habits
yeah yeah um so
i guess i can dive maybe it's something
to save for for after but um yeah yeah
let's dig into that after yes
yeah
right
um i guess g52 and three are different
gpd one just has an extra classification
head for certain tasks yeah
yeah
great yeah good questions
so yeah we've just seen that we can use
a transformer in this kind of
pre-trained and binding setup where we
have some kind of a lot of unlabeled
data um in the pre-training setting and
we have just a little bit of data in the
fine-tuning setting and we can solve a
lot of language tasks in in this way um
and i would say this has become the
dominant paradigm in language over the
last couple of years so uh there's
follow-up objectives like bert and t5
which have done extremely good at
pushing the soda
but there's nothing really that says
that these transformer models have to be
applied to language the transformer is a
sequence model and as such it can just
ingest any sequence of bytes and and
model them and when you think about this
like all the data that we consume like
videos or audio they're represented on
our computers as sequences of bytes
right and so you might think oh
could this approach be used to just
model whatever modality we want
and i think this kind of
paradigm is very
at least interesting when when we don't
really have good inductive biases like
we don't so we don't
but one question to ask is does it even
work when you do have really strong
inductive biases so
uh i'm going to present
some work that suggests that the answer
is yes this still works fairly well in
this case um in in the domain of images
where convolutions are already so
popular and proven out
and i'm going to show a second result
very briefly here which is uh dali which
shows that it's strong enough to even
ingest two different modalities and and
be able to jointly
so the first question is how would you
apply gpt to images
and there's a few things you have to do
you have to modify this auto aggressive
next word prediction
objective
so the natural analog is you can think
of images as a very strange language
where the words are pixels instead and
instead you you need to predict the next
pixel at each point and so we can just
change the objective from next word
prediction to next pixel prediction
and of course we want this kind of uh
large yep
[Music]
oh yeah so you just unroll it as a
sequence it's the same way it's uh it's
stored on a computer you just have like
a sequence device yeah yeah good
question
um so in the language setting uh we
pre-train on this large unlabeled data
set
um on the internet and we fine tune on
uh question answering or these other
benchmarks and then images um one good
analog of this situation is you can
pre-train on imagenet without the labels
you have a let's say a low resource uh
low data sorry setting like so far and
you can uh try to attack safari
classification and of course in both
settings you can do fine tuning in gpd
you can do zero shot and i would say the
standard eval on images is you do linear
probes so you take features from your
model um the model is frozen you like
pass through so far through do the model
get some features and you see how
predictive these features are of the
safari classes
is it kind of pixels here which
basically you asked motor to predict the
nice pixel given the
yeah yeah so pixel cnn is an
instantiation of an auto-aggressive
image
model um so what we're asking here is
can we actually take the same
transformer architecture that we use in
language don't make any modifications at
all and just throw
uh so there's no kind of 2d
prior
so yeah i i i'll call this a model that
we train in http or igp2 for sure and uh
here you can see actually what some
completions from the model look like
so on the left column what i'm feeding
in is the pixels of the first half of
the image
and the next four columns what you're
seeing is
different model generated completions
and the right column here is the
original reference image and you can
actually see that the model is kind of
doing some interesting things right if
you look at the last two rows it's not
coming up with kind of symmetrically the
same completion every single time uh
it's like putting these birds in
different settings sometimes adding
reflections
is putting this lighthouse in grassy
areas and like watery areas for instance
so if you buy into this philosophy of
analysis by synthesis we definitely
have some hint of the synthesis part
so i don't have time to go through all
the results with you but i just want to
say that it is fairly successful in this
uh safar setting where where you don't
have much labeled data if you train a
linear model on top of the features you
get um better results than if you
uh do the same approach with a resnet
train downhill whistle so that that's
like the typical approach in the field
you train some resident on imagenet you
get the features oh yeah
oh yeah and if you compare to yeah this
approach generate a generator's model on
imagenet without the labels take the
features it's actually uh better
predictive
yeah
what's the architecture for this is the
same oh yeah
it's exactly yeah yeah yeah yeah it's
the gpu yeah yeah so this um
so you can modify gpt to to have like 2d
bias that you can do to the position
embeddings but we don't do that we just
want to see
can you use the same exact approach yeah
yeah but also there's like metadata
showing about how that sequential should
be reconstructed so like what's the wick
for example oh uh
what can you expect
so the data on this story yes
but when you want to transform the
sequence into an image you have metadata
that will say something like just like
in numpy erase it'll say here's the
stride yeah yeah so you're just going to
rearrange it
what i'm curious to notice is dpt before
it's given an image at least given this
metadata
i see i see okay yeah that's an
extremely good question um
i don't know how this problem is solved
yeah yeah
in this case um we all the images are
have the same shape oh okay okay
okay
yeah so but we don't tell it like the
concept of row within the model like uh
yeah
yeah yeah so it needs to learn it from
the data but yeah the the data looks
like yeah it'll be interesting if it's
like variable image shapes then this
could be like a way to do it yeah yeah
cool
aren't they like
a lot more pixels than their token sizes
uh yeah so this is a pretty low
resolution images um yeah so we can
actually
the the models we're comparing guts are
trained on kind of high resolution
images so i think that makes it even
more impressive um oh yeah we're just
training at 32 by 32 resolution
cool so if we fine-tune these models for
safer classification we can get 99
accuracy which uh matches sheet pipe and
this is g5 for instance is a system
which is uh trained on imagenet with
labels and then also fine-tuned with
labels so yeah it just kind of shows you
even this approach which doesn't really
know about convolutions can do well i
think you're going to hear more about
that next week with lucas's talk
so
by now it shouldn't be surprising at all
that you can model a lot of different
modalities with transformers
so in dolly we just ask
uh what about throwing two different
modalities at the model and seeing if we
can learn kind of uh how to condition on
text to produce an image
and um for instance one thing you might
want it to do is like you you provide
one of these text captions and you want
it to generate some image like the one
below and the easy way to do this is
just train a transformer on the
concatenation of a caption in an image
and of course uh in a lot of these
situations like the idea is very simple
but the implementation and execution is
where the difficulty is and i'm not
going to talk too much about that i
think the focus today is on language but
you can refer to the paper for a lot of
those details
oh yeah so you you like say have a max
captain uh length and you just kind of
cut it off at that length and you can
pad up to that one
right so you can see that uh it can
generate fairly good samples um so if
you want like a storefront with the word
open the eye on it it's not perfect um
but it's unjust at least it's kind of
like reverse ocr problem where you you
take some text and render it uh and it's
kind of typically rendering it in like
office looking places so
uh that's one encouraging sign but i do
think my my favorite results here are uh
zero shocking issue image transformation
so what's going on here is for instance
if your prompt is the exact same cat on
the top as as a sketch on the bottom and
you feed in the top half of it this
image which is a cap
and you ask it to complete the rest of
the image then it'll render the the top
cat actually as like a
um a sketch and you can do the same
thing with like flipping over photos for
instance uh you can zoom in to a photo
of course they're not perfect um but it
has some understanding of what the text
is trying to do yeah um in the captions
originally uh like the training uh in
the training set do they have like
wording such as extreme close-up view
are some examples like that and that's
probably where it's picking up some of
this knowledge from though we don't seek
out these examples um it's just uh yeah
yeah exactly
okay perfect yeah so this is just that
we just go and and do a do a massive web
script there's no kind of we're not
trying to find the examples like this
right and so you can also do things like
colorization right you can take the cat
color red and this has to like kind of
recognize that what the object is in in
the figure um and
yeah and here you can do
stuff like semantic transformations like
adding sunglasses uh into the cat and
you can put it on postage for instance
yeah so this remarkably that you can do
a lot of these like
transform zero shots um it wasn't
trained to do these things specifically
cool
so moving on uh the last section of my
talk today is on codex which is our most
recently released code writing models
and the first question you should
rightly ask here is um
why why train a model on code anyway is
it at this point isn't it just another
modality
and
what is the novelty that that there is
at this point right um so let me give
you a couple of reasons
so first is that gpg3 it had a
rudimentary ability to write python code
already from a doc string or descriptive
method name and we actually didn't train
it on much code data actually i think
there might have been active filtering
to get rid of code data and so we were
surprised that there was this capability
anyway so that you know like if we
actually purpose the model and trade it
on the large amount of code that we can
find maybe something interesting will
happen there
uh next what sets apart code from other
modalities is that there is a kind of
ground truth correctness of a sample and
functions can be tested with unit tests
and an interpreter so this is very
different from language whereas uh to
get a ground truth eval you might need a
human to come in and even then sometimes
humans won't agree like this this is the
better example or this isn't the better
sample
and uh last thing is i used to dabble in
competitive programming myself and yeah
i really wanted to create a model that
could solve problems that i couldn't
cool
so
if yeah
is kind of high level
programming language which is similar to
like our human language so
have you guys ever tried to predict some
even lower level language like
cpp yeah yeah yeah um hey
i think there's yeah there's follow-up
work where we just train on a bunch of
different languages and i don't know the
metrics off the top of my head but i i
have seen some assembly uh writing
models before yeah
cool um
so i guess yeah um continue on the third
from before so we have this this uh
setting where we have unit test and
interpreter so how do we actually
evaluate um these models in a way that's
kind of aware of these two concepts so
the first thing we did was we have a
data set a new data set which is 164
handwritten programming problems
and um these kind of have the format
shown here like there's a function name
a doc string there's a solution
and there's an average of around eight
unit tests per problem and why is it
important that we hand wrote these well
the thing is we're training on such a
large part of github like if you said
okay i'm gonna take like some vco
problems and i'm gonna turn them into an
evaluation that's not gonna work because
there's just so many github repos that
are like oh here's the solution to this
problem so while this doesn't
kind of guarantee that this problem
isn't duplicated at least someone wrote
it without trying to copy it from
another source
um
so here's some kind of examples of unit
tests that you would uh evaluate the
previous function on um i think it's
should be fairly clear that we should be
using this metric uh like this is the
correct kind of ground truth metric to
use i mean humans do use unit tests to
evaluate code and i would say like um if
you're familiar with competitive
programming like you can't manually
judge all like tens of thousands of
submissions that are coming in you need
the unit tests and that is a fairly good
filter
so one interesting point here was uh we
had to create a sandbox environment to
run these um
these kind of generated solutions in
because when you train on github there's
a bunch of malicious code there's a
bunch of kind of insecure code you know
all your models should be sampling that
and kind of running that on your
environment
cool so now that we have an evaluation
data set uh let's define a metric on it
and so the metric we're going to use is
called pass k
and the definition is the average
probability over all the problems that
at least one out of k samples passes the
unit tests
so
if we evaluate this metric by just
taking every problem and exactly
generating kd samples it's actually not
there's high variance uh just kind of
sampling in that way like imagine the
pass rate of a particular sample is
around one over k like uh this is kind
of like an all or nothing metric so
um what we do instead is we generate a
much larger set of samples and greater
than k most of the times it's like
greater than 5k um and we count the
number that are correct and we compute
this unbiased estimator and uh it looks
more complicated than it actually is
it's just complementary accounting you
uh you take kind of uh the number of
combos where all of them fail
cool
so then uh we train our model and uh
like i alluded to earlier uh there's
165
about 160 gigabytes of uh code which is
collected from 54 million repositories
um for efficient training what we did
was we fine-tuned from gpt3 models of
various sizes and um this isn't actually
strictly necessary we find that we can
get to roughly the same uh final loss
and performance without kiss but it is
slower to do it without um without this
returning step and so we already have
these models why not just find from them
and um one extra trick to make training
much faster here is in uh code there's a
lot of runs of spaces right and those
don't get compressed efficiently in
language because you just don't see them
very often so they typically get broken
up into like many separate tokens so we
introduce additionally some tokens that
compress runs of one space and that
makes training maybe like uh
thirty or forty percent more efficient
so this totally won't just be us
yeah exactly yeah
great so once we have these models we
can go and revisit the human eval data
set and i can share a couple of problems
uh to give you a sense of where the
models are at and also what kind of uh
difficulty level the problems in the
data center
so this is a 12 billion parameter model
that passed out is 90 which means that
90 of the samples will pass the unit
test and this is very something like
anyone kind of doing a first day of
python would be able to do so you uh
increment uh all the elements of the
list by one
um
here is a problem where the pass rate is
17 so this is a solution i gave that's
the problem i gave earlier so you are
given a non-empty list of integers you
want to return the sum of odd elements
that are in even positions this might
not sound that much harder to you but
models can often get confused about like
oh like it's odds referring to positions
or elements um and so here you can
actually see that it's doing the right
thing
and uh finally this is an example of
one of the harder problems in the data
set so the password is under one percent
here and so what's going on here is
actually there's an encode function
which takes a string it kind of chunks
it up into groups of uh
three characters and it doesn't stick
like shift on each character and you
have to write a decoder uh something
that reverses this operation
um
so uh you can see that
the model this is a real model solution
so it chunks up the
characters in the same way you can see
that the cyclic shift is the opposite
way so um
up there it takes the first element of
each group moves it to the end and now
takes the last element of each group
okay as i'm wondering um what's the
effect of so like you had a couple of
examples
like this in the comments so like i'm
wondering if the model will be able to
um extrapolate what it's doing by the
examples alone and not relying on the
system right yeah so some of our tasks
there are uh some examples in the
docstream um and some of them don't i
think it's just to kind of match the
distribution of um real kind of tasks we
find uh in the real world like in this
case it doesn't have it but definitely
for the unit test none of those appear
within i'm just i'm just curious like if
you just give it the examples and not do
the description of the task
oh i see i see so can you do like pure
induction where you like don't tell the
task at all um yeah um i
haven't tried it to be honest um i think
it's worth a shot yeah thanks
yep
so yeah at this point um we've trained
codex models we've evaluated on on this
metric the thing is like was it worth
all this trouble right um you you
already have these metrics like blue
that are match based um in language um
couldn't we have just used this to box
we don't need like an interpreter we
don't need like to generate so many
samples and it would be great if like it
kind of like separated out like this um
but what we find is that
this is uh if you take four random
problems from human eval
and you plot the distribution of blue
scores for correct and wrong solutions
you actually find a lot of
distributional overlap right like uh
it's hard to distinguish like
the green from the blue distribution
and so this suggests that blue actually
isn't a very good metric for gauging
functional correctness and that we
actually do need this this new kind of
metric and this this new data set
so now let's explore the setting where
the paths that can pass at k k is
greater than one
and so the first observation we have
here is that the temperature that you
sample at
it affects your past enkei and just for
some intuition um if you do temperature
zero example you're going to get the
same sample every single time you're
doing artifact sampling so it doesn't
matter like how many samples you
generate um you're just going to get the
same password um and but if you're if
you want to generate 100 samples right
um you can afford to make some mistakes
but you just want a very diverse set of
samples so you you can up the
temperature you can see kind of as you
up the temperature the slope of the kind
of number of samples of its pathway um
it becomes steeper
and so you can kind of take the upper
hole of this and you can find the
optimal temperature for for each
number of samples
and so this brings me to personally my
favorite result of the paper which i
call the unreasonable effectiveness of
sampling
and so let me explain what's going on
here so this is the number of parameters
in the model and here you have pass rate
at 1 and a pass rate at 100.
and the reason i use this term
unreasonable effectiveness is that i
think there's a world where if the
orange line and the blue line weren't
that far apart i might not be that
surprised like at
these scales the model it rarely makes
kind of syntactical errors anymore like
the if you run it it'll run and produce
some kind of output
so you you could imagine a world where
um basically what you do the model has
some approach in mind is just repeatedly
sampling that approach and it's just
either right or wrong but instead what
we find is that the model's actually
composing uh different parts and
producing functionally different things
and um you get this huge boost from
under 30 to over 70
just by sampling a lot of samples from
the model
so unfortunately knowing that one of
your samples is correct it isn't that
useful if you don't have access to the
unit test and now one setting where
practical setting where you would care
about this is say you're creating an
auto complete tool right and uh you
generate 100 samples but you don't want
to show your user 100 samples and have
them pick one right um you want to kind
of try to pre-filter but you don't have
unit tests um
so can we kind of approximate this
oracle sampling with some other ranking
heuristic
so um here i'm showing a couple of
different heuristics um like you could
randomly pick one but they'll but the
one that seems
most promising is to to rank by me
and um
it's i i know like kind of maybe not
theoretically well grounded but in uh in
language this kind of heuristic is
fairly strong as well
so recall that what we're doing is we
have this evaluation set um where we
have kind of standalone functions we
want to produce solutions to them
but
when we're doing training uh there's a
lot of code that isn't relevant for this
task for instance there's a lot of
classes that we're seeing there's
actually data classes too which aren't
relevant at all and actually there's a
lot of incorrect code on github too so
um we might be modeling incorrect
solutions as well as correct ones
so
uh one thing we thought was let's
fine-tune codecs on further on a couple
of data sets where they are standalone
functions and you have
kind of more guaranteed correct
solutions to that
so what we did was uh we found these
problems from a couple of sources so one
is competitive programming problems you
can go on these sites um oftentimes
they'll just give you the unit test
sometimes when they don't give you the
unit test you can submit incorrect
solutions and they'll tell you the first
one you failed on and you can kind of
keep inserting that
so you can get a lot of competitive
programming problems
and another source is
projects where continuous integration is
enabled so why are these useful because
you can actually kind of uh do an
execution tracing so when you run the
integration test you can get all the
inputs to two functions that are called
in their outputs as well and so you
actually have the the true function body
you know what the test output is
supposed to be so you you know kind of
the ground truth inputs and outputs and
um these are kind of like two orthogonal
data sets one kind of helps you with
like algorithmic kind of tasks and one
is more kind of like can i manipulate
command line utilities
and pass this back
so this brings us to the main figure of
the codex paper so
really what we're seeing is a
progression of capabilities so with gpk3
on this human eval data set the password
at one is uh zero basically um you can
generate like one or two lines go here
and never never really a whole program
coherently
um
now when you fine tune on code which is
codex's orange line you start to see
some kind of knowledgeable performance
on this data set
when you do this super additional
supervised fight tubing that's this
green line uh you get even better
passwords and then if you
kind of
generate 100 samples from this model
re-rank with mean log p even better pass
rates and finally of course if you have
access to an oracle um it gives you the
best passwords
uh so one question here is can you
actually use the d-ranking to like like
further to the model can you use it for
like as a backdrop signal yeah yeah um
so we would explore that um i don't know
if i can say too much about these
results yeah
yeah
and finally i i don't want to suggest
that these these models are perfect they
have a lot of limitations that human
programmers don't run into so one is
like uh
actually all generative models are auto
regressive generative models kind of we
have some problems with binding so when
there's like a lot of variables going on
like a lot of operations going on so
that's like hard to figure out which
operation is finding to which variable
so you can kind of see some examples of
that on the left and uh one other kind
of counter intuitive behavior is
composition so we can take a bunch of
very simple building blocks like uh take
a string and reverse it or or like
delete every third character or
something and a human like if you can
chain two of these operations you could
probably change n of them but our models
aren't able to do that yet
cool so moving on to the conclusion
uh we
have four main points in today's talk so
first progress in neural language
modeling has been fairly rapid
and at gpt it wasn't the result of a
push on language modeling and more a
result of work on pushing unsupervised
learning in language
the third point is that auto aggressive
modeling is universal and it can yield
strong results even when there are
strong inductive biases like in images
or in texas
and finally uh we can produce strong
cogenerating models by fine-tuning gpt3
on code
and uh sampling is an unreasonably
effective way to improve model
performance
cool now to end with some
acknowledgements i want to thank my
codex primary co-authors uh some mentors
at openai and um the algorithms team
which i have worked very closely with
great thank you guys for your attention